and how much would immigration fall by
if Briggs it were to happen well the
thing we'd be able to do is get the
figures under control and what I think
is so scandalous about the figures today
is that they show the failure of the
government and indeed of several
departments of state the home office
number ten the Treasury all said that we
would be able to bring these numbers
down to the tens of thousands that is
not proved possible I'm in favor of
immigration I'm in favor of the benefits
that it brings to our society but I have
to say that what is happening at the
moment is being done completely without
the consent of the British people they
voted at the general election to bring
net immigration down to the tens of
thousands we've just heard that it is
going up every year it's now I think EU
net immigration alone represents a city
the size of Colchester 77,000 new
immigrants have come here without any
kind of job at all despite the promises
that we heard from the Prime Minister
and others that they would get changes
in the EU treaty insisting that people
would have to have a job before they
came here and for me this is about
democracy it's about control and it's
about consent at the moment what is
happening is not with the consent of the
British people and the only way to
achieve that is to take that control it
may be about principles but it's also
about numbers and you've gone through
some of the numbers yourself is it your
expectation that in the event of brexit
you could be looking at net migration
down to the tens of thousands is it
possible to realize that hitherto were
impossible to achieve aspiration in the
event of brexit I think it certainly is
possible in the sense that you would
take back control at the moment what is
happening is that the government is
pushing down very unfairly on say
talented engineers from India or
paramedics from Australia or whatever
happens to be and has absolutely no
control over huge numbers coming from
the EU 28 and we would be able to decide
our immigration policy on
NEADS of the british economy you'll
report her just now said of course we're
always going to need immigration and
that's absolutely true i until recently
was mayor of a city that has thrived
with large-scale immigration but you see
the pressures on public services you see
the waiting lists in hospitals in GP
surgeries and of course in schools
people are feeling it and I think what
they resent is the lack of control okay
if you're going to promise the people
that you can bring this down to the tens
of thousands
then you need a means of doing so but
the only means of doing so is to take
that control on June the 23rd that point
is contested by many people and one of
them is max Hastings I think some time
would have been your editor at The Daily
Telegraph when you were in Brussels he
writes in the Daily Mail this morning
he's a reluctant remainer
I think it is self described himself as
being and he says this he says we we may
regain power to keep out Polish plumbers
and Romanian car washers but a large
proportion of the migrants we least want
will continue to land at Heathrow and
overstay visas exploit relationships of
people already domiciled here and he
concludes by saying our hazard a wild
guess that leaving would enable us to
cut immigration by perhaps 15 percent no
well I don't agree and I think there's a
very good point that Max Hastings makes
there which is that under the current EU
system it is indeed true that we cannot
deport people who overstay their welcome
indeed we cannot deport people who are
associated with terrorism or criminality
because of the Charter of Fundamental
Rights which is now applicable across
the whole of the EU area and that is a
real problem for us for the venue of
several recent cases where the Home
Secretary has been unable to send over
stairs or people we don't want in this
country back because of the EU and again
we would be able to do that if we left
on June the 23rd if we vote to leave on
June the 23rd I think the crucial point
here is that we have seen huge numbers
now coming in and I think the public
feel
of course wherever welcoming people we
understand the benefits of migration
what we don't understand is how
politicians can continually tell us that
they will restrict the numbers to the
tens of thousands and then find that
you've got every year a city the size of
New Castle arriving in population yes
country is at the current rate of fire
the population of this country is going
to go up to 70 or 80 million very very
shortly and that is a change a massive
change in our lives but I don't think
the people of this country have
bargained for okay the time we took that
control yeah of immigration and and go
ahead with immigration support our
agriculture support our businesses but
do it with the consent of the British
right well look immigration you know
immigration clearly is a key issue and
to some degree it's becoming a more
probably prominent issue within the camp
that you speak for or partners before
it's not the only issues it matters to
people we've talked about let me just
for the question there another important
subject clearly is security and defense
and some important people come forward
and talk like this on both sides of the
argument had some senior former generals
ending this week making some important
points but let me put this quote to you
from a speech to David Blunkett former
Home Secretary and and crucially Home
Secretary at the time of 9/11 and in
part of his speech he says this today he
says the meetings we held at the justice
and Home Affairs Council at a
europe-wide level after September 11th
were illustrative of the importance of
the ability to work quickly and
effectively with all those who were then
part of the Union is that not a perfect
illustration of how actually the EU
enhances security of moments of great
peril and danger I think this is an
illustration of the fundamental
misunderstanding about what we're trying
to leave the there's no no one on my
side of the argument is saying that we
would detach ourselves from important
international European meetings about
defense about security about
counterintelligence about working on
trying to stop mass illegal migration
but all those things that David Blunkett
described taking place in 2001 can be
done at an intergovernmental level they
do not need to be policed by
Brussels commission they do not need to
be adjudicated upon by the European
Court of Justice in Luxembourg they do
not need to be part of the rush to build
a federal European super-state
a United States of Europe which is
effectively what they are trying to
create
so all that cooperation could continuing
there are plenty of people you'll you'll
have heard from penny Mordaunt who's a
defense minister who believes our
defence would certainly not be
compromised John Hayes the security
Minister is also on the leave camp
everybody understands the need to
cooperate to protect our security what
you don't need to do is remain part of
the federal system which takes away
power from the UK Parliament power from
the people and in classic instances
being our inability to control
immigration we talked a little bit about
the economy the IFS report yesterday
which talked about short-term recession
we had a treasury forecast which I'm
sure you would have criticized at the
start of the week as well tactically
there is a census that not theirs coming
through from some people who feel the
shrewdest thing to add on from your
perspective would have been to say look
yes there's going to be a short term
here there may be some recession the
economy may go backwards for a period of
months possibly even years but that
ultimately is a price worth paying
rather than actually what's been going
going on which is people saying on your
side look we just don't know would it
not have been shrewder to say yes
there'll be a hit but it's a price worth
paying
well actually I think be the best
authority on this was the prime minister
who decided to hold this referendum
awhile back and said that he thought
there would be an awful lot of scare
mongering but actually Britain could
prosper perfectly well and strike
cradles perfectly well outside the
European Union that is so I think the
fact of the matter we're hearing an
awful lot of stuff at the moment from
the remain side that I think he's
starting to lose touch with credibility
any type of probability whatsoever they
are going on and on about the downsides
to such an extent that I fear they are
starting to talk the UK down we are a
great country were a great economy we
are
prospering and flourishing in all sorts
of areas which have absolutely nothing
to do such as the tech sector which have
absolutely nothing to do with our
membership of the EU if you look at what
has happened in with our trade with the
EU over the last other EU partners over
the last 20 years actually other
countries the outside of the EU have
done far better than us in exporting
both goods and services to the EU
countries are whilst not being fettered
and encumbered with that vast body of
undemocratically imposed and USA and you
would say that vast body is exemplified
no better than in the personage of
jean-claude Juncker the European
Commission president who if I can if you
can just unable to dash off but even
just indulge me for another minute or so
this is what he's had to say recently
inviting you to Brussels on an
educational visit have a listen I'm
reading in which papers that Louis
Johnson spent part of his life in
Brussels it's time for him to come back
to Brussels in order to check in
Brussels if everything is telling which
people is in line with reality I don't
think so well I'm afraid what I'm saying
to the bridge people is in line with
reality and if we vote to remain which I
sincerely hope that we don't on June the
23rd then they will go on with measures
to take us further into a federal
European super-state the whole exercise
in Brussels is not aimed at propping up
the Euro that is the entire mission of
the the European Union they will try to
create a fiscal union a political union
Germany who is effectively the paymaster
of this whole enterprise will want to
insist that there is an economic
governance of Europe that in my view
will eventually become profoundly it's
already profoundly anti-democratic but
it will tend towards the creation of the
United States of Europe into which I'm
afraid Britain will inevitably be sucked
by the usage of single market mechanisms
and I'm afraid we have not been able to
get out from under the obligation
of paying for this whole exercise
ourselves who saw what happened with the
Greek bailout we were hooked on that too
okay totally with that Boris Johnson
thank you timer thanks a lot